EVERYBODY AND WE ARE GOING TO BE
STARTING -- THE COMMITTEE AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE BECAUSE WE DO NOT
HAVE EVERYBODY HERE YET BUT WE
ARE FORTUNATE THAT WE'RE GOING --
TO HAVE A PRISON TATIAN FROM --
CABS A THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF VETERAN SERVICE
AGENCIES -- CHECK HELL GET ITS --
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AND A U. S.
ARMY VET HIMSELF WILL MAKE THE
PRESENTATION AND BE AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS FROM.
MEMBERS SO WELCOME. TO OUR
COMMITTEE HEARING AND THE P.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO START
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE GLAD TO BE HERE
TODAY TO PROVIDE A PRESENTATION
ON THE STATE OF THE VETERAN
COMMUNITY REPORT THAT CAST A
CONDUCTED RECENTLY --
CALIFORNIA'S YOU WILL KNOW IS
HOME TO NEARLY ONE POINT EIGHT
MILLION VETERANS -- THE LARGEST
VETERAN POPULATION BY FAR IN THE
IN THE NATION -- AND
UNFORTUNATELY -- THESE VETERANS
ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
REPRESENTED AMONG CALIFORNIA'S
ALMOST POPULATION.
AND EXPERIENCE MENTAL HEALTH
SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND EMPLOYMENT
CHALLENGES FAR GREATER.
THAN THEIR PEERS -- THOUGH GRANT
THROUGH A GRANT FROM THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION.
CABS HAS BEEN -- HAS BEGUN THE
PROCESS OF COMPILING THREE
CONSECUTIVE REPORTS.
ON THE STATE OF VETERANS MENTAL
HEALTH IN CALIFORNIA.
SO THE THIS BRIEF PRESENTATION
WILL PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
VETERANS SERVICE AGENCIES.
A SUMMARY OF THE RELEVANT
HIGHLIGHTS FROM THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN STATE OF VETERANS
COMMUNITY REPORT -- IN THIS
REPORT IS THE FIRST OF THREE
SUCH REPORTS FUNDED BY THE NHS
AWAY SEE AND WILL SERVE AS A
BENCHMARK FOR THE POLICY
DEVELOPMENT AND PROVIDE A BASIS
FOR WHICH WE CAN EVALUATE
PROGRESS.
I WILL ALSO REVIEW CABS IS
VETERAN ACTION AGENDA.
FOR TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND A REPORT --
AND AND TOUCH ON OUR TWENTY
NINETEEN REPORT IN PROGRESS
THERE AND THEN -- GIVE YOU AHEAD
QUICK HEADS UP ON THE THAT ON
VETERANS MENTAL HEALTH SUMMIT
THAT'S UPCOMING IN AUGUST.
SO THESE ARE THE MEMBERS OF
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION VETERANS
SERVICE AGENCIES A CONSORTIUM OF
SEVEN NONPROFIT VETERANS SERVICE
PROVIDERS WORKING IN PARTNERSHIP.
TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIANS VETERANS.
CABS IS JUROR GEOGRAPHIC
DIVERSITY -- FACILITATES THE
DELIVERY OF DIRECT SERVICES IN
BOTH URBAN AND RURAL REGIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
STRETCHING FROM EUREKA TO SAN
DIEGO.
AND UNIT US VETS IN AND LOS
ANGELES AREA VETERANS RESOURCE
CENTER IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
VETERANS VILLAGE SAN DIEGO OF
COURSE AND AND SAN DIEGO -- US
OF A VETERANS US.
CALIFORNIA VETERANS FOUNDATION A
DOWN AND IN CENTRAL VALLEY --
AND SOURCED POSH SHARES VETERANS
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION --
OUR MISSION STATEMENT FOCUSES ON
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING EDUCATION.
HOUSING AND MEDICAL NEEDS FOR
CALIFORNIA'S VETERANS AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
NOW ALL TURN VERY BRIEFLY TO
DISCUSSING SOME OF THE MORE
PROFOUND FINDINGS IN THE REPORT
THAT WE DID IN -- TWENTY
EIGHTEEN FIRST OF ALL -- MENTAL
HEALTH AND AND HOMELESSNESS ARE
CLOSELY LINKED.
AND WE HAVE BEEN FORTUNATE TO
RECEIVE A THREE A THREE YEAR
GRANT FROM THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OVER SECOND ABILITY
COMMISSION.
PART OF THAT GRAND INCLUDES A
REQUIREMENT THAT WE PRODUCE
THREE ANNUAL REPORTS.
THE IMAGE HAS ALWAYS SEE IS MADE
OF VETERANS A PRIORITY
POPULATIONS OF THESE REPORTS
WILL DOCUMENT THE STATUS OF
VETERANS.
MENTAL HEALTH AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS QUITE A MESSY SLIDE BUT
ALL SUMMER IS SUMMER AS IT
BRIEFLY FOR YOU MY APOLOGIES --
BUT IT DOES A CLEARLY HIGHLIGHT
THE FACT THAT CALIFORNIA HAS A
VERY SIGNIFICANT VETERANS
POPULATION ACROSS OUR STATE AND
MANY OF WHOM ARE CONCENTRATED IN
THE COUNTIES OF ALAMEDA.
SACRAMENTO SANTA CLARA.
SAN BERNARDINO RIVERSIDE SAN
DIEGO ORANGE OF COURSE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY WHICH HOUSES MOST
OR CHEN AND FORTY HOUSES MOST OF
OUR HOMELESS VETERANS.
ARE VETERAN POPULATION IS AGING --
OVER 70% ARE OVER [inaudible]
FIFTY PREDOMINANTLY CAUCASIAN --
OVER 90% MALE AND DOMINATED BY
VIETNAM ERA VETERANS ABOUT 40%
OF THE POPULATION IS STILL
VIETNAM VETERANS.
AND THIS AGING DISTRIBUTION
CHARGES JUST -- IS SYMBOLIC IN
IN IN ONE WAY AND THAT IS IT IT.
DISTINGUISHES A GROWTH IN AGING
OF OUR VETERAN POPULATION IN THE
NEXT DECADE THE NEXT TEN YEARS.
IMPLYING OF COURSE THE NEED FOR
SENIOR CARE AND THE COST
IMPLICATIONS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
POPULATION WAS SIGNIFICANT
HEALTH ISSUES.
THIS IS A REPORT CARD TO PICK
NEXT TWO SLIDES COVER REPORT
CARD AND BASED ON OUR RESEARCH --
WE PREPARED THE SCORECARD TO
IDENTIFY SPECIFIC AREAS OF
CONCERN.
OUR FINDINGS INCLUDE THE
FOLLOWING CALIFORNIA'S SPECIFIC
AREAS OF CONCERN. ELEVEN
THOUSAND FOREIGN SEVENTY TWO
VETERANS ARE HOMELESS.
OF THAT 29% ARE HOMELESS YEAH OF
OUR 20% OF OUR HOMELESS US
VETERANS WITH 667% OF THOSE 60%
AND PERCENT OF OUR VETERANS ON
SHELTERED.
CALIFORNIA'S VETERAN SUICIDE
RATE IS TWENTY NINE PER ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND POPULATION.
SLIGHTLY UNDER THE NATIONAL RATE.
BUT TWICE THE RATE PER ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND AND OUR GENERAL
POPULATION.
SADLY AS WE LOOK AT ANY IN FOR
ANY REAL DATE DATA ON OPIATE
OVER TO THOSE IN VETERAN
INCARCERATION WE REALLY WEREN'T
ABLE TO FIND ANY SOLID
CALIFORNIA'S SPECIFIC
INFORMATION THERE IS SOME
NATIONAL DATA UP THERE -- THE
AND THAT IS AN ITEM THAT WILL BE
LOOKING AT MORE CLOSELY -- WHEN
WE DO A REPORTED? TWENTY
NINETEEN SEVENTY WILL LACK AGAIN
ANYMORE DATA BUT WE ARE GOING TO
BE COLLECTING THAT I'M SURE IN
THIS NEXT -- NEXT CYCLE.
GET A CHALLENGE SUBSTANTIATED BY
THEIR SUPPORT INCLUDE THE FACT
THAT CALIFORNIA'S HAD A A LARGE
INCREASE IN HOMELESSNESS AND
SHELTERED VETERANS.
AND WOMEN AND AND WOMEN VETERANS
CONSTITUTE A GROWING NUMBER OF
HOMELESS VETERANS.
ARE SUICIDE RATES FOR VETERANS
ARE STILL VERY HIGH AND JUSTICE
INVOLVEMENT WITH VETERANS WHILE
WE DON'T HAVE SPECIFIC DATA.
IS IS IN OUR WORK WITH THE WITH
THE COURTS IS A SIGNIFICANT
CONCERN IN OUR COURT SYSTEM.
OTHER KEY CHALLENGES CALIFORNIA
LACKS A DEDICATED INADEQUATE
FUNDING STREAM FOR MENTAL HEALTH
AND SUPPORT SERVICES FOR
VETERANS OLDER VETERANS.
REPRESENT 50% OF HOMELESS
VETERANS AND WILL INCREASE OVER
THE COMING DECADE.
AND THE COST OF CARE WILL
INCREASE DRAMATICALLY DUE TO
THIS POPULATIONS CHRONIC HEALTH
CONCERNS.
CONVERSELY A LACK OF
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING.
WAS SUPPORT SERVICES WILL IMPACT
HER YOUNGER VETERANS AND WOMEN
VETERANS IN NEED OF EARLY
SUPPORT.
SO WHAT IS OUR STATE ACTION
PLANNER TELLS CABS AS ACTUAL
PLAN FOR THE STATE FOR DRESSING
THESE CHALLENGES.
THAT ARE CONFRONTING OUR
VETERANS IN CALIFORNIA.
FIRST WILL ACTIVELY ENGAGE IN
STATE AND FEDERAL HOUSING POLICY
INITIATIVES SORRY [inaudible]
SECONDLY.
SUPPORT EXTENSION OF AN
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THE
VETERANS HOUSING AND HOMES FOR
THE ENGINE PROGRAM -- THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ONE FOR YOUR BILL --
AND ALSO THE NO PLACE LIKE HOME
PROGRAM -- WILL WORK TO IMPROVE
THE VETERANS HOUSING HOMELESS
PREVENTION PROGRAM GUIDELINES
AND THE SAME WITH THOSE FOR THE
NO PLACE LIKE HOME GUIDELINES --
INSURING THAT VETERANS -- AND
AND AND VETERAN SPECIFIC
SERVICES ARE INCLUDED IN THOSE
PROGRAMS.
OF FOLKS ON OLDER VETERANS WOMEN
VETERANS POST NINE ELEVEN
VETERANS AND FAMILIES WITH
CHILDREN AS PRIORITY POPULATIONS
FOR MENTAL HEALTH CARE AND
SERVICES.
AND FINALLY SEEK STATE AND
FEDERAL FUNDING FOR MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND OTHER
SUPPORT OF SERVICES. TO BETTER
SERVE OUR THE H. H. P. AND NO
PLACE LIKE HOME HOUSING PROJECTS.
OUR ORGANIZATIONAL PRIORITIES
FOR TWENTY NINETEEN INCLUDE.
BUILT ON THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
REPORT BENCHMARKS THAT WE'VE
JUST DISCUSSED DISCUSSED REFINED
VETERAN RELATED DATA.
AND COMPLETELY YOU'RE TO REPORT
BY THE END OF AUGUST.
TWENTY NINETEEN AND CONDUCT OF
VETERANS MENTAL HEALTH SOME OF
THIS YEAR.
SIDE OF FOURTEEN COVERS ARE OR
WHAT WE HAVE PLANNED TO DO --
TWENTY NINETEEN REPORT AND WE
ARE WELL ALONG IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THAT REPORT WHICH
WILL BE DONE IN AUGUST OF THIS
YEAR -- IT'LL COVER THE EVOLVING
NEEDS OF OUR VETERANS POPULATION
GENERALLY -- VETERANS MENTAL
HEALTH TRENDS SINCE THE TO
TWENTY EIGHTEEN REPORT -- WHICH
WILL GIVE US IN SOME WAYS AN
EVALUATION OF HOW WELL WE ARE
DOING AND WHEN YOUR TIME FRAME
THAT WILL TELL US MUCH.
BUT WE'LL DO IT AGAIN IN TWENTY
TWENTY AND HOPEFULLY IT'LL GIVE
US SOME SIGN.
OF PROGRESS.
UPDATE THE CAVS ACTION AGENDA
AGAIN FOLLOWING -- THE REPORT
WELL DONE IF I SPECIAL
CHALLENGES AND OPPORTUNITIES --
WILL ALSO BE DOING A SIX COUNTY
LOCAL PLAN REVIEW OF THEIR LOCAL
MENTAL HEALTH PLAN TO SEE IF
THEY ARE.
A PROVIDING SERVICES INSIDE AND
SERVICE DOLLARS FOR VETERANS
LIKE THEY'RE REQUIRED TO DO.
THE VETERAN SUMMIT WILL BE
HOLDING ON AUGUST FOURTEENTH IN
SACRAMENTO AND THE GOAL OF THE
SUMMIT IS TO BRING TOGETHER.
THE BRIGHTEST MINDS IN MENTAL
HEALTH SUICIDE PREVENTION
JUSTICE INVOLVEMENT IN VETERANS
AGING. TO A FOSTER LEARNING
INSPIRE HOPE AND PROMOTE ACTION
IN HELPING.
THE NUMEROUS VETERANS IN
CALIFORNIA SUFFERING
CATASTROPHIC AND EVEN FATAL
REPERCUSSIONS FROM THEM. FOR THE
MENTAL EMOTIONAL EFFECTS OF WAR
AND MILITARY SERVICE.
WE HOPE THAT YOU'LL BE ABLE TO
ENJOY IT AND AND AND AND JOIN US
AT THE SUMMIT NEW ARE YOUR
OFFICES WALL BE -- RECEIVING
INVITATIONS.
SO CLOSING -- THIS REPORT AND
THE SUBSEQUENT TO REPORTS WILL
CHALLENGE CALIFORNIA TO CONTINUE
ITS KEY ROLE.
IN VETERAN DEVELOPMENT AND
VETERAN DEPLOYMENT THE VETERAN
DEPLOYMENT CYCLE BY COMPETENTLY
AND COMPASSIONATELY RHYS.
RECEIVING HOMER SERVICE MEMBERS
AS A TRANSITION TO CIVILIAN LIFE.
AS HOME TO THE LARGEST VETERANS
POPULATION IN THE US CALIFORNIA.
HAS UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY TO LEAD
THE NATION WITH A DEMONSTRATION
OF THE WILL AND THE ALLOCATION
OF THE MEANS TO DO RIGHT BY OUR
VETERANS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
AS A CABS UP AS CALVES ARE
PREPARES THE TWENTY NINETEEN
REPORT AND WE GO THROUGH OUR
SUMMIT.
WE DO ALSO DO SO WITH HIGH
EXPECTATIONS AND HIGH HOPES AN
AND A DEEP APPRECIATION TO THE
LEGISLATURE.
AND THE MENTAL HEALTH OF THAT
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES IN
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION FOR THEIR COMMITMENT.
TO VETERANS AS A PRIORITY
POPULATION WITH REGARD TO MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS.
I JUST WANTED -- TO YOU HAD
MENTIONED THAT THERE IS A SIX
COUNTY PLAN REVIEW YES WHAT WHAT
WHAT ARE THE SIX COUNTIES -- I
WISH.
I WISH YOU HADN'T ASKED ME THAT
OF YOU DON'T I SHOULD KNOW THAT
IT IT HONESTLY ANSWER MAYBE WE
WE ARE.
WE'RE FOCUSING -- ORANGE COUNTY
HAD IS ONE LOS ANGELES COUNTY IS
ANOTHER -- I BELIEVE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY IS A THIRD -- WERE DOING.
CENTRAL VALLEY MONTEREY COUNTY.
AND IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA --
NAPA.
AND THERE'S ONE OTHER NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA JUST NOT THINKING
ABOUT THAT BUT IN THE PLAN
REVIEWS AND AND WE'VE DONE -- WE
DON'T ACTUALLY THIS WILL BE OUR
THIRD CYCLE OF CONDUCTING THESE
REVIEWS AND IT'S NOT IT'S FOR
SIMPLY LOOKING AT THE PLANS.
AND SEEING A VETERANS OR EVEN
MENTION IN THE PLANS BUT THEN
DRIVING A LITTLE BIT DEEPER TO
SEE IF THAT MENTIONING IS.
IS ACTUALLY MEANINGFUL IN TERMS
OF PROGRAMS AND IN TERMS OF
DOLLAR COMMITMENTS AND WE FOUND
THAT WHILE VETERANS ARE
SOMETIMES A MENTION IN THE
REPORTS AND THEY'RE REQUIRED TO
BE BY THE WAY -- THE THE PROGRAM
COMMITMENT OF THE DOLLAR
COMMITMENT SIMPLY AREN'T THERE
ON THE LOCAL PROGRAMS THAT WE'VE
LOOKED AT ANYWAY.
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER THANK YOU
SO.
WHAT IS YOUR INVOLVEMENT WITH
THE COMMUNITIES THAT DO THE
STANDELLS FOR THE VETERAN
HOMELESS VETERANS?
ACTUALLY -- IT'S OF THAT'S A
VERY INTERESTING QUESTION
BECAUSE OUR OUR VETERANS VILLAGE
OF SAN DIEGO WAS ACTUALLY I
THINK THE FIRST.
AGENCY TO DO IS STAND DOWN -- IN
CALIFORNIA AND SO WE'RE ACTIVELY
INVOLVED THEY JUST HAD THEIR
STAND ON A WE HAD A CABS A BOARD
MEETING DOWN THERE JUST -- WHEN
THEY HAD THE STAND DOWN ONE IS A
TWO MONTHS AGO?
SO WE'RE ACTIVELY ENGAGED WORD
WHERE THEY'RE AT ALL THE STAND
DOWNS AND ALL THE COUNTIES THAT
WE SERVICE SO THAT WERE
CONNECTING WITH VETERANS AND AND
AND CONNECTING THEM TO SERVICES.
YEAH AND THAT'S YOUR ABSOLUTE
BEST CHANCE.
TO MAKE THAT CONNECTION I KNOW
THAT -- YOU KNOW THE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE.
CONSTRAINED IN SO I LOOK FORWARD
TO YOUR YOUR FURTHER SUPPORT IN
IN ANY WAY YOU CAN TO MAKE SURE
THESE HAPPEN.
BECAUSE THAT'S ONLY ONCE A YEAR
THAT THESE.
HOMELESS VETERANS ARE GETTING
THE SUPPORT.
FROM THE COMMUNITY AND IN THIS
KIND OF FASHION.
NO ADDITIONAL FOOD CLOTHES
DENTISTRY -- VETERANS COURT ALL
OF THE SERVICES THAT ARE BEING
PROVIDED AND AND WE NEED TO BE A
MAKE SURE THAT.
THE OTHER WE CAN EXPAND ON THAT
GOING THROUGH YOUR THROUGH YOUR
WORK BUT ALSO FORCES BEEN DOWN
THERE YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT
AND AND I THOUGHT IT AND ALL
THAT MANY THAT MANY OF THE
MEMBERS MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE ACTUALLY SWING BY THE
THE STAND DOWNS WHEN THEY CAN
AND VERY.
MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT.
TO ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
IS PETRIE-NORRIS THE HAD THE
MENTAL HEALTH SUMMIT THAT'S
PLANNED FOR AUGUST IS IS THIS
THE FIRST YEAR YOU'VE DONE NOT
OR IS IT AN ANNUAL.
YES IT IS IT'S THE FIRST YEAR
THAT WE'VE DONE THAT WE WE PUT
IN THE MIDDLE OF OUR OUR GRANT
OR THREE OR GRANT CYCLE SO THAT
WE COULD KIND OF GET.
MOTIVATED AND GET WELL ORGANIZED
SPORTS SO WE'RE VERY EXCITED TO
BE DOING IT RIGHT HERE IN
SACRAMENTO OVER AT THE AND NICK.
THE CALIFORNIA ENDOWMENT
FACILITY THAT'S A COUPLE BLOCKS
AWAY.
GREAT LOOKING FOR STUFF THANK
YOU.
OUR RIGHTS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR YOUR TIME IN OUR AT ISSUE.
OF AND WHILE SENATOR ARCH LED
ALWAYS COMING OUT THE FACT THAT
THE SECRETARY CITIES TO THE ROLL
CALL.
IRWIN HERE.
VOEPEL [inaudible]
BOERNER HORVATH [inaudible]
BRO.
DALY.
FRAZIER.
GLORIA.
MATHIS [inaudible]
MURATSUCHI PETRIE-NORRIS
[inaudible]
SALAS.
WE HAVE A QUORUM ALL RIGHT AND
CAN I SEVENTY PLEASE MOVE THE
CONSENT CALENDAR -- SO MOVED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA --
SECONDED BY ASSEMBLYMAN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MATHIS SPACE FOR THE ROLL
CALL.
THE MOTION IS BE ADOPTED -- WHEN
I -- WHEN I VOEPEL?
VOEPEL AYE BOERNER HORVATH BRO.
WROTE I DALY.
DALY AYE FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I AM MURATSUCHI
PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS I SALAS
[inaudible] SEVEN ZERO OUR
RIGHTS AND WILL COME SENATOR
ARCHULETA AND WE ARE GOING TO BE
HEARING FROM YOU THIS AFTERNOON
ON SB.
TWO EIGHTY NINE YES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU -- MANAGE
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMAN -- I
AM SO PLEASED AND HONORED TO BE
HERE AMONG VETERANS AND THOSE
WHO HAVE.
JUST HEARD WHAT I JUST HEARD
THAT THERE'S PEOPLE OUT THERE
READY TO SERVE REPRESENT
VETERANS AND ALL OF US ARE DOING
THAT EACH AND EVERY DAY AND I
THANK YOU. FOR FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION AND TO THE
VETERANS THAT ARE IN THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE.
I'M HERE TO REPRESENT -- SENATE
BILL TWO EIGHTY NINE WHICH WOULD
ALLOW ACTIVE DUTY SERVICEMEMBERS
TO MAINTAIN THEIR PLACE ON THE
MEDI CAL HOME AND COMMUNITY
BASED SERVICE WAITING LIST.
IF THEY MAINTAIN RESIDENCY IN
CALIFORNIA WHILE ON DEPLOYMENT.
EXISTING LAWS THAT WISHES
VARIOUS SERVICES UNDER THE
MEDICARE PROGRAM THAT AN ABLE
INDIVIDUALS.
WHO WOULD OTHERWISE BE PLACED IN
A LIVE IN FACILITY TO LIVE AT
HOME AND IN THEIR COMMUNITIES AS
A FAMILY?
SB TWO EIGHTY NINE KEEP FAMILIES
TOGETHER WAS STILL PROVIDING THE
CARE THAT THE SPECIAL NEEDS
INDIVIDUALS REQUIRE.
THE FAMILY MEMBERS OF THE
SERVICE MEMBER.
AS WE KNOW ACTIVE DUTY SERVICE
MEMBERS CAN RECEIVE TRANSFER
ORDERS AT ANY TIME.
AND OFTENTIMES THESE ORDERS MOVE
THEM.
AND THEIR FAMILIES COMPLETELY
OUT OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
CURRENTLY THIS MOVE HAPPENS AND
THESE FAMILIES SOMETIMES LOSE
THEIR POSITIONS ON THE WAITING
LIST.
OF THE CALVET SERVICES.
THIS IS A PROBLEM FOR ACTIVE
DUTY SERVICE MEMBERS WITH FAMILY
MEMBERS WITH SPECIAL NEEDS.
AND SOMETIMES IT'S EVEN THE
SPOUSE NOT JUST THE CHILDREN
WITH SPECIAL NEEDS.
WHO PLANNED TO RETURN TO
CALIFORNIA AFTER THEIR SERVICE
IN A FULL FILLED IN THE RETURN
FROM OUT OF STATE SERVICE TO
COME BACK TO CALIFORNIA?
THIS BILL IS STILL VERY VERY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT WOULD ALLOW
THE ACTIVE DUTY SERVICEMEMBERS
TO MAINTAIN THEIR ELIGIBILITY
STATUS.
OR THEIR PLACE ON THE MEDI CAL
HOME AND COMMUNITY BASED SERVICE
WAITING LIST.
UPON RECEIVING ORDERS TO
TRANSFER OUT OF THE STATE IF THE
ACTIVE DUTY SERVICE MEMBERS AND
THEIR FAMILIES MAINTAIN THEIR
RESIDENCY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THEY WILL REMAIN ELIGIBLE AND
HOLD THEIR POSITION ON THE
WAITING LIST AND THAT IS THE
PRIMARY PURPOSE WHEN THEY LEAVE
THEY LOSE THEIR PLACE TO COME
BACK.
THAT WON'T HAPPEN AGAIN. THIRTY
FOUR STATES ALREADY PASSED
SIMILAR LEGISLATION THESE
MEASURES HAVE PROVEN TO BE VERY
BENEFICIAL TO THE MILITARY
FAMILIES.
THIS BILL SUPPORTED BY SEVERAL
BETTERS ORGANIZATION AS WELL AS
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH.
ADVOCATES.
WITH ME TODAY I HAVE NED WE CAN
LEAVE REPRESENT THE UNITED
STATES MARINE CORPS WHOSE
MEMBERS HAVE BEEN IMPACTED BY
THIS ONGOING ISSUE.
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN I WOULD --
LIKE TO TELL YOU RIGHT RIGHT OFF
THE BAT THAT I AM SO PROUD TO BE
HERE.
AND I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
SHOW -- IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS.
MY FELLOW SERVICE MEMBERS HERE
TO ANSWER.
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT BECAME A
MARINE CORPS INSTALLATIONS WEST
JUST WANT A QUICK ANECDOTE THAT.
SUMMARIZES SOME THE PURPOSE OF
THE BILL I WANT FAMILY STATIONED
AT CAMP PENDLETON A CHILD WITH
US SERIOUS DISABILITIES THEY
WERE ON THE LIST -- FOR IN HOME
CARE.
RECEIVED ORDERS STEINORTH
CAROLINE OVER THERE FOR YOU A
YEAR AND A HALF RETURN BACK TO
CAMP PENDLETON AND THEY HAD LOST
ABOUT FIVE YEARS ON THE WAIT
LIST HAD TO BEGIN THE WHOLE
PROCESS AGAIN SO THIS BILL WOULD
ADDRESS THAT KIND OF ISSUE --
IT'S REALLY PART IN NO IT
DOESN'T GIVE ANY SPECIAL
PRIVILEGES DOESN'T JUMP ANYONE
AHEAD IN THE LINE ALL IT'S
TRYING TO DO IS EASE SOME OF THE
HARDSHIPS THAT ARISE FROM
MILITARY SERVICE.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT ANY OTHER TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT.
HAPPENING CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME
IS SET THREE WITH THREE
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
REPRESENTING AMERICAN GI FORM
AMVETS CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTY VETERANS SERVICE OFFICERS.
CALIFORNIA STATE COMMANDERS
VETERANS COUNCIL NATIONAL GUARD
ASSOCIATION.
AND THE VIETNAM VETERANS ON
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER SUPPORT ANY
OTHER TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION
ANY QUESTIONS FROM.
MEMBERS ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER.
NOT SO MUCH A QUESTION BUT KIND
OF A STATEMENT.
IT'S APPALLING THAT THERE WOULD
BE A LIST OF ANY KIND OF KIND IT
ANY.
SPECIAL NEEDS FAMILY WOULD HAVE
TO WAIT FOR ANYTHING NUMBER.
ONE AND I APPLAUD YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD BECAUSE
THEY SHOULDN'T BE DISPLACED
BECAUSE OF SERVICE TO THEIR
COUNTRY -- BUT I THINK THAT WE
REALLY.
ARE ARE MISSING THE THE INITIAL --
REASONS FOR THIS IS WE SHOULDN'T
HAVE A LIST WE SHOULD BE MAY BE
PROACTIVE IN MAKING SURE THAT
ALL PEOPLE WITH SPECIAL NEEDS TO
BE TAKEN CARE OF ON A REGULAR
BASIS.
AND I THANK YOU FOR THAT.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS ALL RIGHT WE
HAVE A MOTION BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MATHIS WE HAVE A SECOND.
ALL RIGHT ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAILY.
AND SECRETARY PLEASE DO THE ROLE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WOULD YOU
LIKE TO MAKE A YES ZING SO I
WOULD LIKE TO COLLEGE EYES AS I
WOULD LIKE IF THAT COMMITTEE AND
MADAM CHAIR AND ESPECIALLY FOR
YOUR SERVICE -- FOR THE SUPPORT
FOR A MILITARY FAMILIES AND AND
YOU'RE RIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IT'S A SHAME THIS HAS TO COME UP.
BUT IT CAME TO ME BECAUSE OF MY
SERVICE -- AS LA COUNTY
COMMISSIONER MILITARY BETTER TO
FAIRS OVER THE YEARS AND THE
NUMBER OF VETERANS THAT I'VE
REPRESENTED AND SO WHEN THEY
FOUND OUT I WAS THE CHAIR --
HERE IN THE SENATE SIDE THE CALL
STARTED COMING IN AND THIS WAS
AN ISSUE THAT STUCK MY HEART IT
I WAS LIKE YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I COULDN'T
BELIEVE THERE WAS A NEED FOR
THIS SO NOW WE CAN GO AHEAD AND
AND GIVE THESE MEMBERS THIS
FEELING THAT WHEN THEY DEPLOY.
THEY KNOW THAT THEY'LL HAVE THAT
LIST -- RIGHT THERE WAITING.
FOR AND I THANK YOU AND I I VOTE
GREAT FELL.
AND THE MOTION IS -- DO PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS -- WHEN I --
WHEN I VOEPEL?
VOEPEL I BOERNER HORVATH
[inaudible]
BRO.
I DALY.
DALY AYE FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I MURATSUCHI.
PETRIE-NORRIS. THREE NORTH AYE
SOLACE.
SALAS AYE. EIGHT ZERO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND THAT BILL IS OUT
THANK YOU VENTURE ALL RIGHT AND
NEXT WE HAVE SENATOR GLACIER.
YEAHHE WILL BE PRESENTING SB
SIX FOUR FOUR GOOD AFTERNOON
SENATOR.
AFTERNOON EVERYONE LOW.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE
TODAY.
ARE THE LEGISLATION THAT'S
BEFORE YOU WOULD PROVIDE RUN A
RELIEF TO ACTIVE DUTY.
SERVICE MEMBERS BASED IN
CALIFORNIA.
BY REDUCING THE AMOUNT OF THE
SECURITY DEPOSIT SERVICE MEMBERS
ARE REQUIRED TO PAY TO TO MOVE
INTO A RENTAL UNIT -- THE BILL
WOULD ALSO PROHIBIT LANDLORDS
FROM DISCRIMINATE AGAINST
SERVICE MEMBERS FOR HAVING TO
PAY LESS SECURITY DEPOSIT -- IN
ADDITION SB TWO TWO TWO BY
CENTER HILL AND FORCES THIS
PROVISION.
BY PROHIBITING DISCRIMINATION IN
THE RENTAL MARKET BASED ON
VETERAN OR MILITARY STATUS.
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING CRISIS
CRISIS MAKES A PARTICULARLY
DIFFICULT FOR SERVICE MEMBERS TO
FOR THE UP FRONT COST.
OF MOVING INTO A A RENTAL UNIT
IN CALIFORNIA.
ALTHOUGH SERVICE MEMBERS RECEIVE
A BASIC ALLOWANCE FOR HOUSING.
FROM THE MILITARY IT'S OFTEN NOT
ENOUGH TO COVER THE UP FRONT
COSTS OF RUNNING IN CALIFORNIA
AND WHILE SERVICE MEMBERS IN
CALIFORNIA RECEIVE A LARGER
ALLOWANCE.
DUE TO THE HIGHER COST OF LIVING
WHICH I THINK WAS NOTED IN YOUR
ANALYSIS.
IT CAN TAKE MONTHS FOR THE
ALLOWANCE INCREASE TO TAKE A
FACT.
WHEN SERVICE MEMBERS TRANSFER
HERE FROM OTHER STATES?
THIS FORCES SERVICEMEMBERS TO
HAVE TO RESORT TO LOANS AND
OTHER FORMS OF CREDIT TO PAY FOR
THAT SECURITY DEPOSIT.
AND THAT FIRST MONTH'S RENT THIS
BILL TRIES TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE.
TO MAKE SURE OUR ACTIVE DUTY
SERVICE MEMBERS ARE ABLE TO
AFFORD RENT -- ART THESE BRAVE
MEN AND WOMEN WHO -- DO SO MUCH
FOR OUR COUNTRY DESERVE OUR
SUPPORT IN AND THIS IS AN
EXAMPLE OF WHERE WE CAN HELP
THEM OUT WE HAVE A WONDERFUL.
COLLECTION OF SUPPORT GROUPS --
BEHIND IT AND WITH ME IS -- SET
THREE ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
GI FORM OF CALIFORNIA AND THAT'S
FROM THE ABOVE CALIFORNIA AND
THE CALIFORNIA STATE COMMANDERS
VETERANS COUNCIL OF THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS SET
THREE BUT THREE GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS REPRESENTING AMERICAN
JACK FORM AND THAT CALIFORNIA'S
TAKE MINUTES VETERANS COUNCIL ON
THE VIETNAM VETERANS OF AMERICA.
ALL IN SUPPORT.
I WANT TO START BY THANKING
SENATOR GLAZER FOR BRINGING THIS
LEGISLATION THAT WILL HELP
SERVICE MEMBERS.
SB SIX FOUR FOUR WOULD REDUCE
THE AMOUNT OF SECURITY DEPOSIT
SERVICE MEMBERS HAVE TO PAY FOR
RENTAL UNITS BY ONE MONTH THE
MILITARY ORGANIZATIONS I
REPRESENT.
BELIEVE THAT THE BRAVE MEN AND
WOMEN WHO SERVE OUR COUNTRY AND
ARE BASED IN CALIFORNIA MERIT.
YOUR HIGHEST CONSIDERATION FOR
THE RENTAL RELIEF THE SB SIX SIX
SIX FOUR FOUR PROVIDES.
IS NOT EASY TO MOVE TO A
DIFFERENT STATE WITH A SHORT
NOTICE BUT SERVICE MEMBERS TO IT.
AND THEY DO IT BECAUSE THEY
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEIR COMMITMENT
TO THE ARMED FORCES MEANS.
WHAT IS MORE DIFFICULT FOR
SERVICE MEMBERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES TO AND THERE ARE IS THE
STRESSFUL PROCESS OF FINDING
HOUSING IN A SHORT PERIOD OF
TIME?
WHEN THEY'RE TOLD TO COME TO
CALIFORNIA THIS PROBLEM IS
COMPOUNDED BY THE LACK OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING?
SERVICE MEMBERS MUST HAVE SOME
KIND OF RELIEF I AM UNAWARE OF
ANY OTHER PROFESSION.
OR YOU DO NOT.
RELOCATE.
WHERE IF YOU DO NOT RELOCATE TO
WHERE YOU ARE TOLD TO RELOCATE?
TO YOU COULD LOSE YOUR JOB SB
SIX FOUR FOUR IS A FAIR AND
NECESSARY APPROACH TO MITIGATING
AGAINST THE PROBLEM SERVICE
MEMBERS FACE.
WHEN THEY MOVED TO CALIFORNIA?
THE UNIFORM CODE OF MILITARY
JUSTICE ALSO CODIFIES THE
STANDARDS OF CONDUCT THAT
SERVICE MEMBERS MUST FOLLOW
WHICH PROVIDES SIGNIFICANT
PROTECTION FOR LANDLORDS LOOKING
TO RECOUP ANY LOSSES.
AS MENTIONED BEFORE.
IF FINANCIAL OBLIGATIONS ARE NOT
MET SERVICE MEMBERS CAN FACE A
MYRIAD OF DISCIPLINE ACTIONS.
THANK YOU AND I URGE AYE BUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER AT
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
ANY TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS SINNERS
WANNA BE CLEAR THIS IS FOR
ACTIVE DUTY PERSONNEL ONLY.
YES SIR OKAY AND AS YOUR WITNESS --
REMARKS UCMJ DOES HAVE VERY
STRICT.
ARTICLES FOR SOLDIERS.
TO MESS UP THEIR HOUSING UNITS
AND ENSURES THAT THEY WILL PAY
IN FULL AND I I KNOW THERE'S
SOME CONCERNS OUT THERE BY
REALTORS AN APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION -- SO I JUST WANT ON
RECORD FOR PEOPLE TO REALIZE
THAT UCMJ IS.
NOT TOLERANT ALL WHEN THESE
THINGS COME UP.
AND BEING A SERGEANT FOR TEN
YEARS I KNOW WE WERE NEVER
TOLERATE -- FOR PEOPLE LASSEN UP
ON THESE TYPES OF THINGS SO AS
NOT SIR WE'RE WE'RE NOT RUNNING
THESE OUT TO BE FRIED HOUSES FOR
YOUNG SOLDIERS -- SO.
A I JUST WANT THAT OUT THERE SO
MAYBE THAT WILL EASE SOME OF THE
CONCERNS -- BECAUSE IF THEY DO
MASS UP THAN IT DOES ATTACH
THEIR WAGES. FOR PAIN THESE
THINGS OFF CELL.
I THINK IT'S JUST WORTH BEING
SAID THAT WAY NOBODY HAS ANY
HICCUPS ON IT AND WITH THAT'LL
SECOND YOUR BILL. FOR ALL RIGHT
SAID ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- AND I
APPRECIATE THE THE NOTION BEHIND
THE BILL -- I WAS A REPRESENTS
SAN DIEGO.
PERSONAL PASSIONS ON HOUSING
ISSUES THIS IS A CONVERGENCE OF
THINGS I CARE A LOT ABOUT.
CAN THE SENATOR TALK ABOUT WHY.
YOU DIDN'T WHAT WHY.
I KNOW WHY WE'RE TARGETING THIS
TICKET POPULATION AS MUCH OF THE
TESTIMONY ABOUT THE UNIQUE
NATURE IS A MILITARY SERVICE BUT
I THINK IT'S FAIR TO SAY THAT
THE CONCERNS THAT YOU REPRESENT
IN THIS BILL ARE APPLICABLE TO
MOST TENANTS IN CALIFORNIA.
pCHOOSE TO GO DOWN A MORE
EXPANSIVE ROAD -- YEP TAKE THE
GIVEN THE OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
THAT YOU THAT YOU'RE GETTING --
THROUGH THE CHAIR -- IT'S
BECAUSE THE RAT FIRST LINE
SENSITIVE TO ANY LANDLORDS AND
I'M SENSITIVE THE REALTORS
POSITION BUT BECAUSE THE UNIQUE
REQUIREMENTS OF BEING AN ACTIVE
DUTY SOLDIER AND UNITED STATES.
I THINK THERE IS A REASONABLE
REMEDY FOR ANY CIRCUMSTANCE THAT
MIGHT ARISE THAT IS UNIQUE TO A
SERVICE MEMBER VERSUS OTHER --
MEMBERS OF THE POPULATION SELL
IT IS BECAUSE I'M I'M SENSITIVE
TO WHAT I DON'T WANT ANYONE
MESSING UP THE UNIT NOT BEING
HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR IT.
AND I THINK IN THE CASE OF
SERVICE MEMBERS THERE IS REAL
ACCOUNTABILITY THERE THAT ISN'T.
APPLICABLE TO THE REST OF THE
POPULATION AND THAT'S WHY IT'S
DESERVING OF THAT.
PRODUCTION ONE MONTH'S RENT.
WHAT ANALYSIS IF ANY HAS BEEN
DONE?
THAT WOULD INDICATE WHETHER OR
NOT THIS WOULD PUT SERVICE
MEMBERS AT A COMPETITIVE
DISADVANTAGE FOR NINETEEN IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR.
RIGHT AND THAT THAT'S THE ISSUE
OF DISCRIMINATION RIGHT AND SO --
AS I MENTIONED IN MY TESTIMONY --
THAT THERE ARE PROVISIONS THAT
WOULD PROHIBIT THAT TYPE OF
DISCRIMINATION IT COULD GO ON
BECAUSE THAT A SERVICE MEMBER
SAYS I I AM AN ACTIVE SERVICE
MEMBER AND I DESERVE A REDUCTION
IT'S POSSIBLE BUT WE ARE PASSING
LAWS.
AND WE HAVE A REQUIREMENTS IN
PLACE.
TO HOLD THAT LANDLORD
ACCOUNTABLE IF IT WERE TO HAPPEN
BUT NO ONE CAN.
SURE THAT -- IT WON'T OKAY WHEN
SOMEONE SAYS I'M A STUDENT EVEN
THOUGH WE PROHIBITS
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST STUDENTS
AND HOUSING.
THEY COULD STILL MAKE A CHOICE
AND SO.
THAT THAT IS THAT THAT IS A
POTENTIAL UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES.
OF THIS LEGISLATION I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE IT AND IF I DID FIND
IT TO BE A PROBLEM OUT THERE I'D
COME BACK AND ASK THAT THE BILL
BE REVERSED THAT REALLY WAS THE
CONSEQUENCE I CERTAINLY WE'RE
NOT.
AIMING TO TO DO THAT FOR THAT
BECAUSE WE THINK THAT'S THE
LIKELIHOOD BUT IT IS A
POSSIBILITY OKAY IT IS -- I JUST
I I OBSERVE THAT -- YOUR CITY IS
REALLY HOT HOUSING MARKET THE
VACANCY RATES EXTREMELY LOW I
THINK SERVICE MEMBERS BY VIRTUE
OF THEIR PROFESSION AND THE THE
STRINGS THAT COME WITH THE
PROFESSION IS THE MISSION BY YOU
AND BY MY COLLEAGUE.
MISTER MATHIS -- PLUS THE THE DH
IS REALLY RELIABLE SOURCE OF
INCOME -- IS PAID ON TIME THESE
ARE COMPETITIVE ADVANTAGES THAT
THEY GET I WOULD WELL AS RISE
READ THIS BILL LAST NIGHT I
UNDERSTAND EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE
GETTING AT I DO QUESTION WHETHER
OR NOT IT CREATES.
PERHAPS THE OPPOSITE INTENDED
FACTS AND YOU JUST.
GAVE TESTIMONY SAYING THAT YOU
WOULD CHANGE IT IF IT CAME TO BE
THAT THE STAFF THAT THIS WERE TO
BECOME LAW WHO WERE FOUND TO BE
ACTUALLY HARMFUL THAN HELPFUL TO
VETERANS. FOR SERVICE MEMBERS.
I THINK THAT WOULD BE -- FIRST
UP ON IN LINE -- TO TO CHANGE IT
THIS THIS BUT BILL BY THE WAY
CAME TO ME FOR MY SERVICE MEMBER
LEAD FROM MY I HAVE A I HAVE A
GUY CAN'T PARK IS IN MY DISTRICT.
AND IT WAS THE MILITARY LEADERS
WHO CAME TO ME AND AND RAISE
THIS ISSUE AS A PROBLEM THEY
WERE HAVING IN MY DISTRICT WITH
HOUSING.
AND TRANSFER OF OF OF SERVICE
MEMBERS TO THE AREA THAT'S WHAT
BROUGHT THIS BILL TO MY
ATTENTION WAS AND WAS IN A STAFF
DRIVEN IDEA IT ACTUALLY CAME
FROM MY FRIENDS IN THE MILITARY
YOU ASKED ME.
TO TAKE A LOOK AT THIS PROBLEM
THEY'RE HAVING MY LAST
OBSERVATION JUST GIVE IN I CAN
RECOGNIZE THIS NOT THE LAST STOP
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS FOR THIS
BILL -- IS CREATING MORE THE
RECORD IT'S IN THE BILL ANALYSIS
OF OF THE NEED FOR IT -- IS IS
MY UNDERSTANDING OF ON SOME OF
MY BASIS AT LEAST THE ON BASE --
HOUSING IS NOT FULLY UTILIZED --
AND THAT AGAIN IS ON A BENEFITS
AFFORDED TO EVERY TEN IT NO
SHOULD BE IT SHOULD BE.
BUT WHEN CONSIDERING THE TO
TALLY FOR HOUSING CRISIS YOU
KNOW HELPING TO EXPLAIN WHY THAT
PHENOMENON HAPPENS I RECOGNIZE
FOR FAMILIES IT'S OFTEN NOT AN
APPROPRIATE PLACE VERTICALLY FOR
SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN.
IT IS A NUMBER OF REASONS WHY --
BUT I WOULD IN FURTHERANCE OF
THE BILL IN ACHIEVING THE POLICY
AND YOU'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE I
THINK EXPLAINING WHY THAT
VACANCY.
RATE IS NOT THE S. NOT THE
ANSWER OPTICALLY WHEN YOU
UNDERSTAND THE IMPACT TO
SUPPORTING COMMUNITIES -- SADLY
THE A SOME OF MY LOCAL CITIES
I'M TO ALWAYS HAVE THE MOST
POSITIVE RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
MILITARY BECAUSE THE IMPACTS ON
MINUTES AS I WAS READING THIS
BILL LAST NIGHT WHILE I'M
SUPPORTING THE BILL HI.
I DON'T WANT TO BE CONFUSED
OTHERWISE -- ANTICIPATING SOME
OF THE PUSH BACK AND TRIED TO
HELP CREATE THE LEGISLATIVE
RECORD ABOUT WHY THIS IS
NECESSARY AND WHY BETWEEN THE
THE ALLOWANCE THAT IS PROVIDED
OVER ABOVE THE SALARY.
COUPLED WITH THE ON BASE HOUSING
THAT'S IT'S A PRETTY LUCRATIVE
BENEFITS ASSUMING THAT IT'S IN
GOOD CONDITION -- AND
GEOGRAPHICALLY APPROPRIATE --
THAT DID THIS BILL STILL
UNNECESSARY AND YOU KNOW THIS IS
SOMEONE WHO THINKS THE HOUSING
CRISIS IS THE BIGGEST ISSUE
FACING OUR CITY I HOPE THAT WE
ARE OUR STATE -- SORRY DIFFERENT
JOB RIGHT NOW -- THAT WE'D BE --
CONSIDERING AND THINKING ABOUT
MORE WAYS THAT WE CAN SUPPORT
TENANTS IN CALIFORNIA NOT JUST
THOSE WHO SERVICE VIDAK DOT JUST
SERVICE MEMBERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MATHIS.
A MR LARA RINGS OF REALLY GOOD
POINT.
AND I I'VE BEEN AND ACTUALLY
SPENT TIME AT CAMP PARKS TO A
GREAT LITTLE PLACE BUT CERTAIN.
CAMPS LIKE CAMP PARKS IN CAMP
ROBERTS AND SEVERAL OF OUR STATE.
ACTIVE DUTY BASIS -- DON'T HAVE
THE ON BASE HOUSING.
WHICH IS WHY THIS IS AN ISSUE --
RIGHT.
I WOULD RECOMMEND TO GIVE EASE.
TO THE PEOPLE THAT HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT THIS MAY BE A PROVISION
WITHIN YOUR BILL.
THAT REQUIRES THEM TO SHOW A
COPY OF THEIR ORDERS.
THAT SHOWS THEY'RE ACTUALLY
STATIONED THERE -- THAT WAY THEY
HAVE PROOF -- BEING IN THE
MILITARY YOU DO GET A SET OF
ORDERS THAT SHOWS WHERE YOUR
STATION -- WHERE TRANSFERRED --
TO THAT WAY THERE'S ACTUALLY
PROOF OF THEM BEING BASED THERE --
THAT WOULD THERE'S SOME OTHER
TYPE OF DOCUMENTATION THAT WAY.
I MEAN.
THEY I THINK THE CONCERN COMES
UP AS IN ANY.
VETERAN CAN HAVE A ACTIVE DUTY
MILITARY CARD AND THEY COULD
HAVE JUST BEEN KICKED OUT.
AND AND GOTTEN A DD -- TWO
FOURTEEN ENOUGH SOMETHING OTHER
THAN HONORABLE.
AND STILL HAVE A VETERAN ID CARD
AND CAN SHOW UP AND THEN GO OH
HEY I WANT RAN.
AND GET IN USING THE S. WHICH
SHOULD BE A CONCERN.
BUT IF THEY HAVE A COPY OF THEIR
ORDER SAYING HEY I JUST MOVED
HERE I JUST GAS STATION HERE
HERE'S A COPY MY ORDERS.
THEN THAT'S SOMETHING COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT SHOWS THEM ON THE UP
AND UP.
WHICH IS A BETTER PROTECTION ALL
THE WAY AROUND IT WOULD REDUCE
ANY FRAUD CONCERNS.
AT THROUGH THE CHAIR.
WHAT YOU ARE THE GOAL THAT YOU
IDENTIFY IS EXACTLY MICHAEL AND
IT'S CERTAINLY IF THERE WAS A
CONCERN THAT THAT TYPE OF AN
ABUSE I WOULD NOT WANT AYE I'D
WHAT I'LL TAKE A LOOK AT IT AND
SEE IF I?
WE CAN MAYBE.
SURE IT'S NEAR A TO NOT UP TO
TRY TO AVOID THAT ABUSE THAT'S
NOT WHAT I WANT AND YEAH IN A
MATTER.
I THINK YOUR YOUR OBSERVATIONS A
GOOD ONE AND LET ME GO TAKE A
LOOK AND SEE WHAT AND IF YOU'VE
GOT ANY QUESTIONS I'D LOVE TO
HELP YOU WITH.
YEAH THANK YOU PROJECTS.
ANY OTHER DISCUSSION ALRIGHT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR JUST.
TO EXTEND MY APPRECIATION TO THE
THE THOUGHTFUL REMARKS IN THE
REPRESENTED FROM SAN DIEGO.
I EACH OF THESE BASES ARE A
DIFFERENT CIRCUMSTANCES
DIFFERENT TO SITUATIONS WITH ON
BASE HOUSING AND SOME WITHOUT IN
MY CASE THAT WE DON'T HAVE A LOT --
AND I APPRECIATE THE SENTIMENTS
ABOUT HOW WE HAVE.
BROADER HOUSING ISSUES HERE AN
ANOMALY TAKEN A VERY SMALL
LITTLE SLICE AND NOT REALLY
MEANT TO TRY TO CREATE A
DISADVANTAGE FOR EVERYBODY ELSE.
BUT JUST TO TRY TO PROTECT THEIR
ACTIVE DUTY SERVICE MEMBERS TO
HELP IN THIS TRANSITION THAT'S
ALL AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR LIVE UP RIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND WE HAVE A MOTION
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER SECOND
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS.
AND MOTIONS TO PASSED WITH
PREPARATIONS.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS.
VOEPEL [inaudible]
I BOERNER HORVATH.
BRO.
BRO I DALY.
DALY AYE FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE GLORIA.
LAURIA I MATHIS.
MATHIS I AM MURATSUCHI.
PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS I SALAS.
SALAS AYE. EIGHT ZERO
REGULATIONS ARE BILLS OUT SEC
YOU THAT'S NOT TO APPROPRIATIONS
OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH RIGHT THANK
YOU
[inaudible]
IT'S SIMPLY MEMBER WE'RE AT JUST
ACCOUNT.
THIS VOTES -- GO THROUGH
MISSPENT.
A DEAR TWENTY THE CONSENT ITEMS
SALAS.
SALAS AYE [inaudible]
WE KNOW.
AND SENATOR JOHN SHOULD BE.
ON HIS WAY
WE ARE.
WE HAVE BEEN WAITING FOR YOU BUT
LUCKILY NOT TOO LONG. FORTY
THREE AND ALWAYS LAUGHED FOR
SIZE.
I WAS JUST INTERESTED IN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF APPEL'S BY
JUST OF CHALLENGES.
ALL RIGHT SO WE HAVE A
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES WITH SB SIX
SIX THREE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR --
S. SENATE BILL SIX SIXTY THREE
PROVIDES A PROPERTY TAX
EXEMPTION FOR PROPERTY OWNED BY
A VETERAN ORGANIZATION.
CURRENT LAW ALLOWS A WELFARE
EXEMPTION FOR PROPERTY TAXES FOR
NON PROFITS SUCH AS RELIGIOUS
ORGANIZATIONS HOSPITALS IN
VETERANS ORGANIZATIONS.
HOWEVER THIS EXEMPTION ONLY
APPLIES TO PORTIONS OF THE
PROPERTY USED EXCLUSIVELY FOR
TERRIBLE PURPOSES.
SUCH AS ROOMS USED FOR
COUNSELING SERVICES THIS BILL
WILL EXTEND THIS PROPERTY TAX
EXEMPTION TO THE REST OF THE
PROPERTY.
SENATE BILL SIX SIXTY THREE WILL
PROVIDE SUPPORT TO VETERANS
HALLS THAT ARE TRYING TO ENHANCE
THE SOCIAL WELFARE.
OF CURRENT AND FORMER MILITARY
PERSONNEL THISBILL IS IDENTICAL
TO SOME WOMEN GRAZE BILL FROM
LAST SESSION.
WHOM I AM PROUD TO HAVE AS A
PERSONAL CO AUTHOR ON THIS BILL.
THIS BILL PASSED UNANIMOUSLY--
LAST YEAR IN BOTH HOUSES BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THE WAS VETOED BY
GOVERNOR BROWN I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE TODAY.
AND WITH ME TODAY IS SET THREE
BY ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
LEGION. THREE JAPANESE CHAIR
MEMBER SAID THREE BUT THREE
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
REPRESENTING AMERICAN JACK FORM
AMERICAN LEGION HIS THE SPONSOR
AMVETS CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
COUNTY VETERANS SERVICE OFFICERS
CALIFORNIA STATE COMMANDERS
VETERANS COUNCIL.
NATIONAL GUARD ASSOCIATION OF
THE VIETNAM VETERANS OF AMERICA.
I JUST LIKE TO MAKE A COUPLE OF
BRIEF COMMENTS -- MY POST IN
PLACERVILLE -- POST ONE NINETEEN
DONATED APPROXIMATELY TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS -- TO AND SOLVE
PLATFORM LIGHTING FOR THE BOYS
AND GIRLS CLUB IN PLACERVILLE --
AND RECENTLY I WAS DOWN AT THE
HUNDRED AND FIRST -- AMERICAN
LEGION STATE CONVENTION AND I
WAS TALKING WITH -- LOS ANGELES
POST MEMBER HE SAID THIS WOULD
SAVE AND HIS DISTRICT.
ARE IN IT AT HIS POST SIXTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR THIS IS
MONEY THAT COULD GO BACK TO THE
COMMUNITY THE VETERANS.
AND AND ULTIMATELY HELP
EVERYBODY THERE IN THE COMMUNITY.
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION I APPRECIATED.
ALL RIGHTS ANY OTHER TESTS ON
HIS PART.
FAST MONEY IN OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS FROM THE PANEL.
ALL RIGHT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE MISTER JONES -- YES THANK
YOU VERY MUCH A ENCOURAGE YOUR
AYE VOTE AND WE ALSO POINT OUT
THAT THE SISTERS ASSOCIATION
HAVE SHOWN THEIR SUPPORT SO --
WE'VE GOT BROAD SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
RIGHT I NEED A MOTION
[inaudible]
OKAY AS THIS WILL BE OUR SECOND
OKAY ALL RIGHT SO -- THE OF THE
MOTION.
SO WE HAVE THE MOTION BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS THE
SECOND BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY
AND THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
LOCAL PLACE -- WHEN I -- WHEN I
VOEPEL?
VOEPEL AYE BOERNER HORVATH I
REMEMBER ABOUT THE AYE BRO.
I DALY.
DALY AYE FRAZIER.
FRAZIER I'M GLORIA.
GLORIA I AM MATHIS.
MATHIS I MURATSUCHI [inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS.
AS I SALAS.
SALAS AYE IT'S TEN ZERO ALL
RIGHT CONGRATULATIONS THAT BILL
IS OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS
WE WILL HOLD.
THE ROLE OPEN [inaudible] FOR
FIVE MINUTES. FOUR FORTY SIX IS
THE END -- YES YES AND IF YOU
COULD ADD ON THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS THAT I'VE MISSED ABOUT.
RIGHT YEAH.
THANK YOU THANK YOU OKAY.
THERE'S A LOT OF THE TOP HUESO
ALL THESE.
INTERNALLY.
ON THE MASTER [inaudible]
OKAY BOERNER HORVATH I AND ITEM
THREE SB SIX FOUR FOUR BOERNER
HORVATH.
BURNER MORE ABOUT THAT
.
DURING THIS MEETING